金ちゃんはじめしゃちょーどっかほぼかかるぞ者ですぐ
嫌だ4日一帯に皆さん年楽ということなんですけどもうみんなで集まる機会っていうの
は多いと思う
親戚とは家族とかねは今雪が多いところですけどもう人が集まると思うピザ食べたく
ありませんか
膝がー
ピザが食べたいんですけどもうビザ員さんの人も毎回そのピザを何回も何回もいろいろ
撮りに運んでたまたまず姉と思うんですよ楽しくないともデフピザ届けててもなるほど
の渡してお金貰って帰るだけそんな繰り返しでねぴ財産もねあんなに化するってよ
なるほどなるほどほぼかそういう日座椅子の人たちにもうハピネスをあげたいんで今日
はて財産の人に
ドッキリあしようと思いまーす
何ようなんですけどもう機ほどちょっと色々買ってきましたここでずっぱりローチと
買ってるだけでいいから
あっ一つ買ってきましたでこれはこのまい棒まあまあで5個の突っ張り棒体重制限が
70キロまであるので僕の体重が65キロなんてこの2つをくださっておけばまず僕は
140機を取りした65キロ南で取れます
のられるの0
それから強いロープを買ってきました今サーブ見てわかると思うんですけどもうこう
いうふうに何かこういうなやばいやつを運ぶんですがこれで良いで今回の作戦としては
この改ざんブラザーズの3人にロープで動くを吊るし上げてもらってたり引っ張って
もらった pizza in 3月て5月以降座って待ってるんですねピンポーンとし
て入るとピザでストップ
た渡瀬ねお会計している時に僕勝手に注力
はぁ
rar
ロープでこなっててあみんな聞いてくれたらを解決に僕は浮きラストであり
ああ
par
年末なんです色んな人がいが見たいと思うさっそくピザ注文することはあっ女性のピザ
食べたいんですけど
はいじゃあそれでお願いしますとメンズがようにいるんですけどね
ですから外す動きをつけてお越しくださいありがとうございます入ってしまいますそれ
じゃあ食べましたよチャスだけ準備にとりかかりますねばいこう
ここにこう2つ湿気て
担任が不可欠引いてもらうなるほどの家族だってきた
やはりたジャズで完全に止めますそこで持っているそうすべて
パラレルこれ時間との戦いだああ
ブーブー一気たよピュアロープ付きいきましょーう式 h kei
まああん
ちょっと枯れないところでしょうから引っ張っていただきます理由
ああああああ
ん
言葉がああ
あれ&悪いですね
書等はございません
最速下がってしまいん
ていません164
4,266円を開けて
ません
me
沿いにあった
car
ん
eran
入っていません
メジャーさんありがとうございましたはぁ
んをっ
ばカウンタの住んでくれたのだそう総務省は8番のザック p はネットってやばいが
途切れたんですアメリカ台場たりスマグラーずさんが来ているのでぜひ皆
いやいやチャンネル登録おねがいいやー
じゃあ